Daily Show host Trevor Noah got who
started in stand-up comedy he's got a
Netflix specials called son of Patricia
and in and he explains why he does not
enjoy camping go camping dude like why
Wow dude leave me why it's amazing
you're kidding me he's like no water and
electricity you know it's just like
awesome the great outdoors you like you
gotta like take a dump and live like in
the hole in the floor or something dude
that was my life to never go camping
again the Emmy Award winner is that with
a new paperback edition of his New York
Times best-selling memoir it's Trevor
Noah born a crime stories from a South
African childhood no his book is adapted
for young readers and he shares his
journey growing up biracial under
apartheid when interracial interracial
relationships were illegal we should
mention that the daily show is on Comedy
Central that's a division of Viacom CBS
and Trevor Noah Noah joins us now from
his home in New York Trevor good morning
good morning to you how's everybody
doing hey we're doing okay All Things
Considered I think I want to underscore
something very unusual about your book
now first of all most books published in
this country never make the bestseller
list your book not only made it but then
came back around and made it a second
time what's going on what's your
reaction to that how did that happen um
I think I've been really fortunate and
blessed in that the book has resonated
with people for different reasons so
when I first wrote it I think a lot of
people gravitated towards the book
because they wanted to learn about
apartheid in South Africa they wanted to
learn about the history of of a country
that had gone through something very
similar to America but very different at
the same time and then what I've
discovered recently has been the
resurgence of the book has been driven a
lot by children strangely enough because
as much as I wrote a book about growing
up in South Africa really the gist of
the book is just the story of me growing
up with my mom and it's a story of
coming-of-age you know it's a story of
being an outsider not knowing where you
fit in the world not knowing how the
world relates to you and I think a lot
of kids
related to that and so that's been the
driving force for why the book has
remained on the New York Times
bestsellers list I've been really
grateful the the book does segue back to
that bit we played at the top where
people were talking about camping and
you're like look that was my life I mean
there are moments in the book where if I
recall correctly you guys have so little
money you're eating wild spinach just
picked off the ground
it's an unusual story in addition to
being Universal in the sense that it is
coming of age as you as you repackage it
leave some things in take other things
out for young readers in this new
edition what are you hoping that they'll
take away from it well the biggest thing
I hope they take away is what you know I
took forever to learn and we all take
forever to learn in life especially as
kids is is that you know in life I don't
think we should be striving to fit in we
should be striving to find ourselves we
should be striving to accept ourselves
and you know I know a lot of kids read
my book and they were like oh wow I
can't believe you know you grew up in
South Africa but you have the same
stresses as me you were you you know you
were worried about getting someone to go
to the prom with you were worried about
you know being liked in school you were
worried about where you fit in your
family was dysfunctional and you you had
issues with that and those issues came
into your life and and so for me
whenever children read the book and
whenever I read passages to kids or
whenever I join in to like little book
clubs the the biggest thing that strikes
me is how similar we are all over the
globe you know we we all have different
lives and we all live in different
countries but when it boils down to it
as human beings there are fundamental
experiences that we're all going through
on very different levels and it's
actually unifying to see for me that
that no matter where you are in the
world no matter what continent you want
you can be experiencing the exact same
thing and I think you can find the same
answers in how to overcome those
obstacles
Trevor Maier used to say that all the
time that we are more alike than we are
different in your book certainly
highlights that the the original version
was 84,000 words for young adults it's
72,000 words you say no profanity no
overt sexual material but in the book
you include
apartheid and how it differs from Jim
Crow laws in the United States I have
questions about that but I won't
why it's important you think to have
those kind of discussions with kids well
I think it's important you know when I
was when I was young I I had a nap and I
had an amazing history teacher in school
who really emphasized the need for us to
learn history and I never understood why
and she always used to say juries used
to say the reason we learn history is so
we can try our best not to repeat the
follies of the past and I think a lot of
the time history and learning of history
has become a divisive thing in many
places in the world because people feel
like we're trying to relive what
happened but I think if anything it
gives us context not just as kids but as
adults in learning where we've come from
how we've come to be here and and I
think you know if you think of history
on a simple level if you remove humans
from it it just helps us understand why
we are where we are today you know so so
if you're going to build a house you get
somebody to come out and survey the land
and they're basically telling you the
history of the land before you can build
the house so you can figure out what
foundation to put on that land and I
think history serves the same purpose
for us without us knowing what the
foundation of the land is we can't
figure out how to move forward as a
society we don't know why anybody is
where they are we don't understand what
structural elements of society have been
in place that have hurt people or help
certain people and so I think that's the
importance with histories just
understanding this is how we got to
where we are today and then this is how
we can move away from what we did
incorrectly in the past and I think
that's the beauty of storytelling that's
the beauty of history and I think people
fights about it way way more than they
should because they put themselves in
the history and then they start to fight
about something that has already
happened yeah we need people to map
those foundations for us and we also
need people to take the particular and
to make it Universal and in that latter
category you're one of the best there is
so Trevor Noah thank you very much for
joining us the paperback edition of
think it's Trevor Noah born a crime is
on sale now you can see the daily show
by the way distancing the daily chef
distancing show weeknights on Comedy
Central